all right so this album man it's out uh  bubble for [ __ ] this probably will come  out right before the album drops out the  25th the 25th 25th don't make mistakes  how much input did m have  on this project if any no  none you just send in the album this is  it him and you know  what about feedback wise did does he  give you feedback yeah yeah but it was  uh  i'm gonna keep it on it i uh i went to  detroit  and i was in you know in the studio and  paul royce  and played him album front to back and  he [ __ ] with every record i was like  this [ __ ] this is ready to go  and that's when like he he jumped on  bang and  50 got on the city on a map joined  like that  even though we lost those records but  that's what i'm saying i i played on the  tape  it was like i didn't have no it wasn't  that was the critique like yo this [ __ ]  is [ __ ] amazing this is ready this is  ready